welcome to the second video guide for
black guards a strategic role playing
game featuring the the dark I universe
and developed by daedalic entertainment
in our last guide we introduced the
different classes today we're going to
take a closer look at the skills and
talents of your characters and this
promised in our last video will also
introduce the free character creation
but to better understand the advantages
of recreation we should first take a
look at the skill system as a whole the
skill system of blackguards enables you
to expand and improve the abilities of
your character and is based on the rules
for the tabletop role-playing game the
dark I anyone already familiar with the
game will immediately feel at home and
for the rest of you will do a quick tour
and show you how to choose and improve
the skills of your party in black guards
and black guards both your character and
the members of your party gained new
adventure points after every fight one
and every quest that is completed you
can use these points to improve the
abilities of your adventurous you can
invest the points in five different
categories base values weapon talents
talents spells and special abilities
base values here you can spend adventure
points to increase the attributes of
your hero attributes like strength or
dexterity influence one or more base
values that will be very important in
combat in addition to this you can also
raise the base values astral energy
vitality and resistance to magic
directly the attributes not only
influenced the base values but also the
probability of successfully using a
talent or casting a spell and they can
be a prerequisite for the learning of
these will explain how this works when
talking about the talents and spells and
in an upcoming video about the combat
system increasing the base values will
turn out to be a very effective
long-term strategy but investing in this
aspect of your character requires
patience the improvements can only be
bored with a high amount of adventure
points that when just starting out will
not be gathered
easily weapon talents the blackout skill
system is designed to offer you as
player as many choices and freedoms as
possible to create your own style of
play the weapon talents are a good
example for these opportunities after
creation every class has already
invested a few points like this warrior
did with the talent excess and maces but
you can also spend points to teach the
character new weapon talents like
crossbows it is basically possible for
every class to learn every single weapon
talent the weapon talent determines the
probability of successfully hitting or
parrying with the weapon in question as
lada allows you to change your fighting
style to be more aggressive or passive
by increasing either the chances for
attacking or pairing of course you can
also decide to keep a balanced approach
these settings can be changed at any
time during the game by accessing the
character sheet so don't worry you won't
have to decide on one style right away
you can try out different settings for
different combat situations range
weapons do not have sliders since they
cannot be used to parry especially at
the beginning of the game raising the
weapon talents is a very efficient way
to increase the chances at hitting and
pairing with a low cost of adventure
points talents additional to the weapon
talents and phase values your character
can also learn talents by investing
adventure points this is an important
investment for technicians all these
talents influence your characters
efficiency in a less direct way in comet
they have to be used in the right way
and at the right time spending porns on
warcraft for example can come in handy
when you have to quickly change weapons
this usually takes the character a whole
round which can be critical for an
archer that is suddenly surrounded by
enemies with enough points in Warcraft
this happens instantly making you much
more flexible in combat other talents
that allow you to set traps get
information about your opponents or
haggler merchant down to lower prices
can also be learned mastering these
talents provides you with a serious
advantage
to mimic the game mechanics of the
tabletop role-playing game the dark I
every talent is based on a combination
of three attributes body control for
instance which allows you to stay on
your feet on slippery ground or when hit
with an intact that would usually down
you is based on courage intuition and
agility the points invested in these
attributes in combination with those
band on the talent determine the chance
of a character staying upright and they
should fold on a higher value in
attributes and talent means a higher
chance of successfully using body
control to resist an attack or the
danger of slipping talents that you
haven't learned yet cannot simply be
activated just like that you always need
to find a teacher first who will impart
the knowledge about the talent for a fee
whenever you meet at each end the game
you should keep in mind where to find
them spells
just like in the tabletop role-playing
game only character skilled in magic can
use spells only majors can invest points
in this category like talents new spells
can only be learned when visiting a
teacher as the ones already learned can
be improved at any time when not in
combat another source can be the rare
spell books you can buy these from
merchants or earn them as a quest reward
spells are divided into the categories
damage protection strengthen and weaken
depending on your style of play your
mage can become a powerful damage dealer
or support your party with helpful
spells every spell has both a skill
value and a level the skill value
determines the chances of successfully
casting the spell and can be rice
directly every spell has four levels
that become available at the scale
values 0 8 13 and 18 with every level
components of the spell like damage
dealt area of effect or duration of
effect change high level spells can also
create completely new effects spells on
higher levels are often harder to cast
and have a higher cost the level you
want to cast the spell at can be freely
chosen at any time for example if you
raise the skill value of the spell
thunderbolt the damage dealt will
increase from first to third level but
always at a higher cost of astral points
on the fourth and final level the spell
changes from a single target effect to
an area of effect spell that needs
damage to several targets in a coup the
chance of successfully casting a spell
is determined by three attributes that
differ from spell to spell as we have
already mentioned in the previous video
magical powers can be greatly diminished
by wearing metal weapons are an
exception to this rule even though
majors have a lot of different
possibilities they are not over powerful
they always have to keep an eye on their
astral energy if they run out of magical
power they'll be next to useless in a
fight and become an easy target for
enemies special abilities
to wrap it up blackguards also offers
the so-called special abilities please
allow your characters to perform special
actions or get a passive boom you can
learn these special abilities from a
teaching special abilities are divided
in four categories melee ranged magic
and passive with these abilities you can
activate new attacks or special boons
like regaining astral points during
combat characters can only broaden the
range of possible attacks by learning
special abilities which is especially
important for fighters many of these
attacks have a lower chance of hitting
successfully but they cause extra
effects if they are successful you
should always calculate whether it would
be more effective to use a risky attack
the deals more damage or to go for a
normal attack with a higher chance of
success free character creation but
let's finally take a closer look at free
character creation which we already
mentioned at the beginning of the video
this is the supreme discipline in
blackguards character creation in this
mode you can freely distribute all your
characters points right at the start and
determine yourself which attributes
talents and abilities will be important
you also have to choose whether your
character should be a mage or not but
choose wisely free character creation
requires in-depth knowledge of the
blackguard skill system if you spend
your points without a plan you might
have to start over again with a new more
competent hero and now it's your turn
show us your character and tell your own
story right here on YouTube or hit the
forums and exchange experiences about
your journeys through aventura on forum
daedalic de you can also of course find
us on Facebook here you can stay up to
date about recent information on date
Alex blackguards background information
and anything important is also posted
here ww blackguards de who didn't join
the blackguards yet but once to catch up
as fast as possible is more than welcome
to register on steam's early access
there's also an awesome collector's
edition featuring an art book a figurine
and much more cool car
10th